[Music]
in the central dogma
the process by which the dna is being
turned into rna is called transcription
once you've made the messenger rna when
it turned into proteins
that process is called translation
proteins are complex polymer
the repeating subunits that are found in
proteins are called amino acids
and there are essentially 20 different
kinds of amino acids
the amino acids have an amine part of
the molecule and they have an acid part
of the molecule
and a variable side chain the variable
side chain can consist of acidic
residues
basic residues hydrophobic residues
based on whether they're charged like
the acids or the bases
or uncharged or hydrophobic or
hydrophilic
the different amino acids has slightly
different properties
each amino acid can hook together by the
amino and the acid part of it and form a
long chain
the side chain's kind of hanging off of
the side
the polypeptide formed can then fold up
sort of like a string of spaghetti
because the polymer part of the chain is
very flexible
however what they like to do is fold up
into a ball
so that the hydrophobic parts of the
molecule will hide away from the water
and the hydrophilic parts will interact
with the water
some of the reactive parts the acids and
the bases are in pockets on the surface
these typically form what are called the
active sites of enzymes
and because those are reactive acids and
bases they can catalyze reactions
for example when you eat sugar that goes
through a process called glycolysis
which involves a series of proteins that
are folded up into a particular shape
such that they recognize glucose the
sugar binds to the enzyme which is a
protein
in what is called a lock and key
mechanism
it fits in a very precise way such that
certain chemical moieties are in close
contact with certain amino acids that
are reactive
typically acids or bases that allows the
enzyme to do a chemical reaction on the
sugar
so the sugar begins to be broken down in
a series of steps
about 15 steps that break down the sugar
allow your body to use the pieces of the
sugar to make atp
that fuel chemical reaction of many
biological processes in the body
some part of the sugar will be used to
make the amino acids that went into the
protein
and some part will be sued to make the
nucleotides that go together to make the
rna
and to make the dna in the most
efficient way
not all protein are enzymes some
proteins have a particular shape that
lets them fit together
and this forms the cytoskeleton which
gives your cells the shape that they
have
and allows your cells to fit together to
give your body the shape that it has
it's the three-dimensional shape of the
proteins that allows them to carry out
their functions
whether it's structural or metabolic or
energy conservation or information
processing
that shape is caused by the amino acids
and their chemical properties
but the trick that makes this work they
have to be hooked together in the proper
order
one after another so a typical protein
may have from one hundred to maybe one
thousand different amino acids
where is that order of amino acids come
from
it comes from the rna and the rna gets
that from the dna
so what the dna code does is that the
bases in the dna go together to tell the
ribosome through the action of the
messenger rna
what order to hook the amino acids
together
this is called the genetic code so in
your dna
you've learned there are four bases a t
g and c
and the order at which those are found
in the dna three at a time
so the order of amino acids that are put
together in the protein by the ribosome
come directly from the information
that's stored in your dna